[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar covid19 pandemic emerging
testing solutions
i'm christy jewell of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by diasoren to learn more please
visit theosorin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many of the questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i would now like to welcome our speaker
dr david ingman
chairman emeritus of pathology cedar
sinai medical center
retired professor of pathology
northwestern university
for a complete biography on dr engman
please click on the presenter tab at the
top left of your screen
welcome dr ingman you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction
i'm david engman
i'm the medallion chairman of pathology
emeritus at cedars-sinai medical center
and retired professor of pathology at
northwestern university feinberg school
of medicine
i have the following disclosures
an overview of the presentation
i've divided this into three parts
the first will be an update on the
covid19 pandemic
with a review of where we stand with
global infections deaths and
vaccinations
and two sections on variants and
vaccines
next section
stars cov2 testing
will review the types of testing and
their uses
their pros and cons
and then
a section on the challenges for
laboratories and healthcare providers
with respect to sars kobe 2 diagnostics
finally i'll talk about covet 19 and
2022 with an outlook for the pandemic
and a discussion of emerging testing
trends
first an update on the pandemic
so global infections deaths and
vaccinations
most of the audience is very familiar
with how these have cracked since the
beginning of the pandemic
a few years ago i'd like to review them
nonetheless first of all
the biology and transmission
remember that one viral particle shown
on the left
can produce thousands of progeny virus
particles from a single cellular
infection cycle
the virus is transmitted through
airborne droplets primarily
in addition to budding out from the
infected cell as seen with the yellow
pseudo-colored virus particles in the
right image
the infected cell can also lyse
releasing not just virions but also
building blocks
of viruses including nucleocapsid
protein all the other proteins that make
up the virus inside and out and that
will be important later on
in terms of the immune response
we normally control
this virus most immunocompetent people
and the immune response induced by viral
infection
involves both humeral or antibody
immunity on the left side of the panel
and t cell or cellular immunity on the
right side
humeral immunity
involves the stimulation of b
lymphocytes
to differentiate this is on the left
side of the panel into antibody
producing cells called plasma cells
on the right side cell mediated immunity
involves the maturation of cd8 positive
t cells
that then differentiate to become
cytotoxic t cells
on the bottom right so the two effector
molecules of the immune system are
antibodies and cytotoxic t cells and
these are what help us to fight the
virus antibodies by blocking viral
binding to host cell surface
and cytotoxic t cells by killing
infected cells
and here is an image
of antibodies binding to sars
virus particles and also in the surround
with the surrounding cells as well
in terms of clinical outcomes based on
omicron
infections the percent of people with no
symptoms is very high
it's four out of five or even higher
only a small number of people 20 to 30
percent develop symptoms that usually
they can manage at home
no hospitalization required
a very small number of people maybe one
percent with omicron
require hospitalization and only a tenth
of those
die of this infection
and finally this
syndrome called long covid
is a multi-organ
infection
infectious sequela of infection
that involves
multiple organs and can in fact affect
many people it's not exactly known
depending on the study it can be 10
percent up to 30 40 percent
have long lasting symptoms of
disinfection
and that's going to be a major challenge
going forward it's how to manage long
covet
over time
i've shown on this chart from the world
health organization
the
number of cases
on the
left y-axis and those are in the colored
bars the track along the bottom of the
graph
and the number of depths which is the
blue line that runs above in the center
of this graph
you can see over time
that different continents have
experienced the majority of cases
at different times during this pandemic
and there's been a very large increase
in total number of cases at the very
right due to this omicron variant i'll
talk more about this later
what i've pointed out with the red text
is that omicron has a very low ratio of
deaths to cases
that is to say
that while the number of deaths before
omicron
tracked in the
tens of thousands of deaths per week
that is also true currently but the
number of cases
has risen from a few million cases per
week through most of the pandemic up to
now over 20 million cases
about a month ago
and so it's no more deadly than it was
but there are many more cases and that's
going to be an important point as we
discuss omicron
this is
equally seen here if you look at the
table on the right side in with the
orange boxes
the cumulative number of cases in death
gives a case fatality ratio of a little
over a percent 1.39
that's the number of deaths divided by
all the cases in the world up to now
but only in the last seven days the case
fatality rate is only 0.53
and that's because omicron is not as
deadly this sort of reproduces the graph
that i showed on the previous slide and
all the details will be available for
your review after this webinar uh are
shown in the table uh to the left
and so i would also point out
that the
case fatality rate is different from the
infection fatality rate which is an
estimated number of the total number of
actual infections
and so the infection fatality rate will
be lower because there are many
unreported infections and i'll talk more
about this as well
a tiny percent of people are actually
accounted for by testing
if you look on this graph which tracks
the percent of estimated covid 19
infections that are actually detected
it's less than 10 percent
in the united states at the present time
of actual infections are reported
to be reported an infection has to be
documented typically by pcr testing
and the reason for this discrepancy
between actual and reported include
asymptomatic infections are not detected
let alone reported people are unaware of
being infected
symptomatic infections
that are either managed at home with or
without self-testing are also not
reported so that gives the
the
tremendous undercount of actual
infections
now let's talk about the variants what
are they and how do they emerge
the sars kobe 2 genome is shown at the
top
the virus uses a special dna polymerase
to replicate its genome called reverse
transcriptase
that reverse transcriptase makes a lot
of errors compared to our own dna
polymerase that replicates our own
genome and introduces point changes or
mutations into the genome
those mutations can occur in any viral
gene
not just the spike protein gene that
we're most familiar with when people
talk about
mutations that might affect antibody
binding or
might increase the receptor
affinity with host cell receptors and
promote viral entry but they can occur
anywhere
in the genome
some of those mutations confer the virus
with a greater ability to spread and
there are several mechanisms of this
i'll describe in a minute but such a
virus can spread better than the
paravirus
and different viruses with different
pathogenic potential and unique
sequences are called variants
here are the spike proteins of some
recent
stars cov2 variants
in yellow is the alpha variants that
emerged in first in the united kingdom
next we have the beta from south africa
then the epsilon from california gamma
from brazil
and delta from india and i'm only
pointing this out to show that each one
of these variant spike proteins has a
different set of mutations that are
colored uh
in the
pictures of the spite protein shown
above each of the labels
so that's just one example but remember
each one of these variants
may have other mutations that also
confer a growth advantage that allowed
each one of these to emerge in turn
you can actually see this
even better by using the gis aid
[Music]
depiction
of variance spread over time on the left
we're talking about the beginning of the
pandemic all the way across the right to
the present time
and you can see that at the bottom
the first one was alpha
shown with the letter a there it's
actually greek capital alpha
then
the beta came on top in the in the
middle of the section
then gamma
then delta and finally it's not all the
ones in between delta and omicron are
not shown those are the greek letters
but omicron at the end
so what's interesting here is that each
one of the variants
arose not from a previous variant but
from elsewhere so you can see the beta
popped up
uh
before gamma which arose a little bit
later from the alpha lineage
delta emerged from beta and omicron
emerged from some part of gamma so
it's very interesting to note that the
new variants that were dominating the
globe actually arose not from the
previous variant that dominated the
population
and you can see out on the left on the
far right side omicron if you go
vertically from those last
you know medium blue
dots there upwards you'll see that there
are no other
uh variants other than omicron at the
present time the only things that are
in
medium blue are omicron at this point
this in the united states is also
depicted this way and you can see the
alpha
gamma and beta and the delta is the big
orange one and that that came up very
quickly to dominate the population back
last summer
and now in the late 2021 and now we see
omicron in purple has sort of taken over
delta it replaced it very quickly within
a month
all the delta was gone omicron replaced
it
good news is that the infection fatality
ratio
of omicron is very low less than 0.2
percent throughout the entire country
with vermont having a little bit
more but this is not a very deadly
uh
viral variant
of course the problem is because we have
so many infections we still have
significant depth
throughout the world and in the united
states because the numbers of infections
are much higher
how does a viral variant rise in
prevalence to dominate in a population
there are many
possible theoretical reasons and some of
these are actual
replication rate if the virus replicates
even a little faster
it will dominate a population fairly
quickly
same thing about the ability to infect
cells
the amount of virus produced by an
infected cell
residents in the upper versus lower
airway viral variants that seem to
occupy upper airway like omicron
tend to produce more shed virus than
those that occupy the lower airway
concentration in airborne droplets
and the persistence of those droplets in
the air
those are other variables that
mutations can affect
longer time of viral shedding if a
person's asymptomatic and actually
shedding virus for
a week instead of four days or two weeks
instead of one week that can also
promote that viral
expansion
the ability to cause asymptomatic
infection where a person's unaware of
being infected may not take the kinds of
precautions that he or she might
if
they had the person had symptoms is also
can promote
shedding and expansion
the ability to evade host immunity
there's been a lot in the lit in the
papers about this although there's been
a focus on that without necessarily
considering all these other
mechanisms that can
promote a variant uh expansion
and i would note though that increased
transmission does not equal the ability
to cause severe disease as we've seen
with omicron which causes less severe
disease so there the two are definitely
distinguishable although some of the
mechanisms involved in causing severe
disease may be
listed in the contained in the list
above
this is just one example
of this is actually
i made this myself just taking uh two
viral variants theoretical variants one
of which has a one percent growth
advantage over the other and you can see
it only takes about 300
uh
cycles before the
variant that can grow a tiny bit better
one percent will dominate that
population so if you were to take a
person and infect them with equal
amounts of omicron and any other variant
uh within a matter of days the only
thing remaining in that person would be
omicron
maybe even less than a few days
vaccines what do they do and what don't
they do
well
all five major sars kobe 2 vaccines that
are used in the united states
uh and canada and or canada work well
you've got mrna vaccines from pfizer
moderna on top the viral vector vaccines
from johnson and johnson and astrozenica
in the middle and the protein subunit
vaccines novavax on the bottom
throughout the world you've got lots of
different viruses that are in different
states of approval emergency use etc in
different countries
and
all of the vaccines work to a greater or
lesser degree they all induce humor and
cellular immunity
vaccination reduces symptoms need for
hospitalization need for intensive care
and death from covid19
and inception recovery does an even
better job of reducing these that is to
say that if someone is infected and
recovers
from covid19 they actually have slightly
better immunity than those who are
vaccinated of course many people have
been infected and vaccinated
vaccination and infection recovery do
not completely prevent a person from
being infected or from infecting others
so while they reduce all those other
parameters
a person
can still become infected and shed virus
to infect others even if they're
vaccinated
and this is also responsible for a lot
of silent infection
silent infection among vaccinated people
allows this virus to persist in the
population and i'll focus more on this
later
vaccine efficacy wanes over time
though
as measured by antibody concentrations
typically and but protection from
serious illness and death lasts longer
than protection from
becoming infected so that's important
people can become re-infected but often
aren't going to develop serious illness
that they might have if they were
infected primarily before vaccination
what about the boosters well you know
there's a lot of discussion about people
now seeking a force booster shot and
maybe planning on a fifth one later this
year
and i should just emphasize
that protection from hospitalization and
death is longer lasting than the
antibody levels might indicate in fact
people thought that we could just
measure antibody levels and then when
they drop to a certain level you might
need a booster at that point but there
isn't a hard fast rule on what that
level is
that and so that has not been
implemented as a public health policy in
any country
testing
let's talk about the types of sars kobe
2 testing and their uses
the molecules for the diagnosis of
sarcobi to infection immunity are shown
on this slide in the left panel on the
top we have rna the nucleic acid genome
of the
covin-19 virus
that rna is coded by nucleocapsid
protein
those two molecules are internal to the
virus
on the lipid bilayer bilayer that
constitutes the viral membrane you can
find membrane protein and envelope
protein these are two integral membrane
proteins shown in purple and blue
and then at the very bottom emerging
from that surface is the spike protein s
it has a couple subunits s2 and s1 and
that's what binds via the receptor
binding domain rbd
to the host cell receptor h2 on the host
cell
infection with this virus induces on the
right panel antibodies
that are produced against typically
spike protein but also all of the other
proteins that are mentioned as well as
others not shown in the diagram
that is to say that infection with this
virus induces
a polyclonal polyspecific antibody and t
cell response to lots and lots of viral
proteins not just the ones that are in
the news
and those antibodies can be used for
diagnosis
let's start out though from the top rna
so rna can be used for molecular
diagnosis
most of the rtpcr reverse transcription
pcr assays include several genomic
targets to really make the specificity
very good this is a very sensitive test
proteins
typically nucleocaptive protein is the
most commonly used
can be used for antigen testing in the
presence of antigen or the rna
may indicate infection
and finally antibodies on the right are
used for serology with anti-spike and
antinuclear captive proteins being the
most popular assays
now the test for different molecules
will be positive at different times
post-infection so shown on this graph
we're tracking the rna levels in red
antigen levels in orange
the igm the early immunoglobulin
antibody in blue and the long lasting
igg in green
so the rna test can be positive
for the first several weeks but many
people can contain they can continue to
have
detectable rna in
a nasal and mesopharyngeal sample
after
virus has been cleared
the antigen test is positive only when
viral particles are around so when virus
is cleared after several weeks the
antigen test may become negative
the igm antibody precedes the igg by a
number of days but typically wanes and
then may be absent
after a few months
while igg persists for a long time
this is during after infection
so depending on when you measure
you'll find positive or negative test
results for these markers
here are the pros and cons of these
tests
for the detection of rna by rtpcr
one of the pros is that the rna can be
easily detected by this molecular test
that level can be measured by
quantitative pcr
and the results are often given in what
are called cycle threshold or ct
with the larger the ct the more rounds
of amplification
were required before the rna signal was
detected
so high ct
means lower rna to begin with lower rna
in the sample
low ct
means it amplifies earlier higher rna
and higher amount of virus
and this can be seen in this diagram
with the high specificity of this assay
shown on the top panel
the process of the rna amplification in
the middle panel by pcr and the
uh viral amplification curves in the low
in the bottom panel with the high virus
on the left with low ct low virus on the
right with high ct the ct is on the x
axis of that bottom graph
so this is how
that's depicted
now the molecular testing is the gold
standard and is in widespread use
throughout the world it's the most
common test
up to now and we'll talk about future
testing as we go forward
the cons it's more expensive and as i
mentioned a few slides ago viral rna may
be present without infectious virus
now rt-pcr may be positive long after
the person has stopped shedding virus
and this graph
shown here demonstrates that
where there's this post-infectious
period where a person can be positive by
pcr
shown after that infectious stage that's
highlighted in the orange shading there
and that is the period where the person
may not be infectious but may be
positive by pcr
and that will be important in this in
coming slides
so what about
so the other thing i would mention is
that the results are not immediately
available
with
detection of rna and this typically
requires testing in a laboratory there
are a few
assays out there that have emergency use
authorization that are sort of
disposable thermocyclers but they're not
in very high use at the moment and
they're not inexpensive either detection
of antigen well the pro of this is that
a variety of antigens can be used
nuclear captured protein happens to be
the most commonly used one
and you can have rapid antigen tests
that can give results in 15 minutes and
the more high throughput
slightly better
laboratory antigen test can give a
result in about an hour
rapid tests can be done at home they're
laboratory antigen tests are typically
qualitative but can also give
quantitative results that may be of use
antigen tests are less expensive than
molecular tests and the laboratory
antigen tests are even less expensive
than rapid antigen tests around half the
cost
those of us many of the people watching
this have purchased these rapid tests
that range in costs from around 10 to
around fifteen eighteen dollars and the
laboratory energy tests are around four
or five dollars so they're even less
expensive
the cons
are that androgen tests may be somewhat
less sensitive than molecular test
but they're equally specific
and that may be not be a problem
it might overcome the problem of
persistent rna in the absence of
infectious virus that i spoke about
and the other big problem as we that we
move through this pandemic is the
results of at home testing are not
reported and not included in national
data or local data
some people may wonder how can this
nuclear captured protein be detected in
a sample if it's internal to the virus
and as i showed at the very very
beginning
when a
virus infects a cell it can actually
lyse releasing all of the building
blocks including nuclear captain protein
from the lyst cell and that's material
is present in an upper airway sample and
detected by antigen testing
now detection of antigen can be done by
these rapid at-home tests or by
laboratory tests
and the rapid tests there are three of
them listed here very commonly used
uh are
available for purchase in many
pharmacies unless they're sold out which
has been a problem in many parts of the
country
these tests basically you take a sample
yourself you mix it with a buffer and
you you place it in that sample chamber
of the rapid test shown
by this person in this image
and typically what happens is that
test card
contains
a line in that we're talking about the
upper right panel of c and t the c is
the control which contains immobilized
nuclear captured protein that's just
immobilized on that strip of paper
the test line contains immobilized
antibodies to nucleic acid protein
and then the sample contains the patient
sample and it's mixed with a buffer
solution that includes enzyme conjugated
antibodies to nucleic acid protein and
some developing or color reagents so
when that sample is spotted in that well
it migrates upward the reaction of
reagent flows on the right
and if the patient sample does contain
nucleocapsid protein
it binds to the antibodies on the t line
that are immobilized on the paper and
then enzyme conjugated antibodies in the
buffer will react with that and develop
it as a line
that gives color
and then also
the enzyme conjugated antibodies do bind
to the c line to the immobilized nuclear
captive protein just to show that the
whole system is working and on the
bottom the positive results can be
either clearly positive on the bottom
left
slightly positive which means positive
in the second uh image
negative in the third image or invalid
on the right side if the control doesn't
light up so
many of us have used these they're
fairly straightforward
after especially after you've done it a
few times it's actually some people
really have trouble using these rapid
tests
there are high throughput assays offered
by a number of companies three are shown
here
and these are somewhat superior to rapid
tests in their performance
uh some of the so-called
laboratory-based antigen tests are
actually low throughput and they're just
automated rapid test readers where you
put the cassette in and it just leaves
that line rather than
using the person's naked eye
but others are high throughput tests
that can analyze hundreds of samples per
day
so for example the diastore and ortho
test list above there they can be walk
away tests requiring very little labor
the laboratory
technologist just loads the samples
presses the button and walks away and
again the results can be available in a
very short time about an hour
how good are these tests
well there was a study that compared
those rapid and automated antigen tests
to rtpcr for diagnosis of infection
and as you can see on the lower left
table
for
samples with cts of less than 25 or less
than 23
the sensitivity is quite high in the 90
range once you get uh to the 30s cts in
the 30s where the viral load is a little
lower then the sensitivity drops
somewhat and on the right side if you
compare the rtpcr test the laboratory
antigen test and rapid energy intestine
on the bottom you'll see that 50 of the
samples of these 87 samples were
actually
detected by all three assays
and
there were five samples detected by the
laboratory test and the rt-pcr that were
not detected by the rapid energy test
how good are they also remember using
that rt pcr is a gold standard
uh both tests perform with cts of 25 or
less so people who are actively shedding
virus are going to be positive with
these assays
there is some thought that samples with
ct above 30 may reflect that virus
or free viral rna below levels that are
infected so for population screening a
high throughput test is very likely to
identify infectious people
very fast and lower than rtpcr
the
rapid tests have been used in large
scale studies recently published showing
that they're very good at detecting
asymptomatic people
it's pretty amazing actually and that
would probably be even more true
of
the laboratory-based test
the pros
of
antibody detection are that serology can
detect both ongoing and prior infection
it can be quantitative
most companies offer high quality
serology tests
and there are rapid serology tests as
well that can be performed at home
the cons are those rapid antibody tests
are very expensive
let's talk about diagnostics and
challenges for laboratories and
healthcare providers
well one of the biggest problems is that
there's been a so-called great
resignation
during this pandemic
and clinical laboratories are really
suffering as a result of that many
people are leaving the workforce
including healthcare workers and
laboratorians
and institutions can't afford to have
the remaining workers out with covid19
so high throughput antigen screening has
low labor requirements and allows the
detection of infectious people
without having the labor requirements of
other testing modalities
so this is a real pressure on hospitals
and political laboratories
emerging trends
so we're going to see more and more of
these at-home tests and actually
the u.s government will send a handful
of tests to every household just need to
go online and order them and they arrive
within about a week
the at-home
antigen tests are already in widespread
views and this is likely to continue
however many people have difficulty
using these tests and i have many
friends who call me and say oh i just
couldn't tell what it was i couldn't get
it to work etc these are educated people
as well
there is covid19 fatigue
this together with the low virulence of
omicron
will lead to continued relaxing of
government mandates and individual
measures that people can take to protect
themselves
however we need to remember this is
still a serious illness for some people
especially the elderly immunocompromised
unvaccinated and those whose immunity
has dropped
over time
this
virus will persist in the population
through silent spread even among
vaccinated people and even those who
continue to wear masks and practice
social distancing it's very contagious
and since it's asymptomatic in many
cases people are unaware of being
infected or of infecting others
and one way to identify those most
likely to be shedding virus is through
that antigen testing which is the least
expensive testing modality
over 19 and 20 22.
so
the outlook
there is an institute
called the institute for health metrics
and evaluation of the university of
washington that publishes a briefing and
is relied upon by many people in uh
health care throughout the world as
giving great forecasts for this pandemic
how accurate are the predictions
and
there's been look-back studies to see
how the predictions were over time and
they were incredibly accurate and became
more precise as time went on there's a
caveat to this though that i'll mention
in a shortly
currently in the world there are 24.3
million
infections
uh per day
estimated from last week
10 000
deaths per day
55 of the world population is estimated
to have been infected at least once
seven percent is the infection detection
rate that is there are 14 times the
actual number of infections than the
reported infections
and omicron remains the dominant variant
throughout the world today
in the united states
we have 890
000 estimated and 166 000 reported daily
infections last week
there are only 2 600
estimated and 2100 reported deaths you
can see that the deaths and estimate the
estimated and reported deaths are closer
to each other because it's hard to under
report deaths deaths are deaths and
they're easily detected whereas
infections aren't so there's a big
disparity between 166 and 894 thousand
this makes coven 19 the number one cause
of death in the u.s uh last week
75
is an estimate for the percentage of
people have been infected at least once
75
and 9 is the infection detection rate in
the u.s so there are 14 times the number
of actual infections from those being
reported
omicron dominates in the u.s as well
the uh
uh 75 percent of americans are immune to
omicron either from vaccination or from
prior infection so that's the good news
in terms of the outlook for next year
we have a cumulative estimate of about
6.8 million deaths in the world as of
june 1st of this coming year
700 deaths by uh
by daily deaths by june 1st so the
number of deaths will drop to a very low
level globally
13 16 million kilometers of deaths by
june 1st
in the united states by mid-april we
should only have less than 20 000
deaths per day
20 000 cases per day
very low hospital census
and less than a million cumulative
reported reported deaths
by june 1st
very low daily reported deaths by early
april and only a little bit over a
million 1.1 million cumulative total
deaths
due to copenhagen by june 1st
now re-infections are becoming of
increasing importance
and i would just
emphasize here
that
a study in england that looked at 650
000 people
uh determined that more that that more
than 650 000 in england have been
infected twice
most were reinfected in the past two
months due to omicron and before
mid-november re-infections accounted for
one percent of cases now that rate is
about 10
so this is something we need to keep our
eye on here as well
this silent spread is a major concern
and this became publicly
obvious
when many sports leagues golf
nba basketball the nfl and major league
baseball
had lots of players testing positive who
were largely vaccinated
largely uh
showing
social distancing and masking but still
getting infected
and this reflects this so-called silent
spread
and there was one excellent study
uh on this matter
that was a longitudinal study in 2021 it
followed 160 symptomatic
people and 160 asymptomatic people and
all of their contacts were followed for
three months by serial pcr testing
87.4 percent
of the positive contact cases were
asymptomatic
that is
all those symptomatic people only about
10 percent had symptoms
all those people who became infected
as expected the pcrct values were higher
asymptomatic compared to symptomatic
index cases
and but there were no differences
between the infectivity rates of index
cases so it's
regardless of whether you have high or
low virus you were still
very well able to infect others this
just demonstrates this problem
what are the challenges ahead
and how accurate were the predictions
again
i mentioned how accurate they were but
what that ihme did not predict was the
omicron
shown in the blue question mark this
peak that just peaked that january is
now declining
so even though they predict no uh
new spikes in the summer april and
beyond that red question mark shows that
we really don't know what's going to
happen at that time
emerging testing trends
at home tests will be continued to be in
widespread use
and people will get more comfortable
using them over time
of course due to this code of fatigue
many people will not test at all even if
they have coven 19 symptoms
health care organizations and others may
be sports leagues or other companies
that need or want to reduce kovud19 will
implement regular screening of employees
or members
we'll be done mostly by rt pcr but also
transitioning to androgen testing is a
lower cost and equally useful
alternative
my final remarks
this sars kobe 2 is a perfect virus
it's very contagious it causes few if
any symptoms in most people
vaccines work well for reducing spread
symptoms and severe disease but they
don't prevent
spread or re-infection
silent spread
will allow this virus to persist in the
population for a long time and animals
that can harbor virus will contribute to
this persistence
domestic animals and others
public health officials
will continue surveillance testing via
our tpcr and possibly high throughput
antigen
testing we just need to monitor this
infection
even if the hospitalizations and deaths
go down as long as that virus persists
it will continue to be a threat
and only time will tell whether a new
variant will spike
and finally waning immunity will lead
more people to develop symptoms or
require hospitalization and perhaps
more boosters so i hope that you
enjoyed this presentation
and we'll have to see what happens in
2022 as we move through
the pandemic onto
a new phase of this disease perhaps
endemicity
and
again it's a major unknown what the
future holds but we all we have the
armamentarium through novel drugs
vaccines and testing to meet that
challenge thank you very much
thank you dr ingman for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of our webinar now a
reminder to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
okay let's get started
we have so many questions that have come
in dr engman let's start with this one
how do you foresee testing needs
changing as covid19 becomes endemic
wow so i i spent a certain amount of
time
uh discussing that
but
i think one thing is pretty clear and
this cove that covet 19 fatigue is a
real thing
most people without symptoms
they'll never be tested unless they have
a reason to be
the only reason that asymptomatic people
would be tested is if they work in a
field that tests
like healthcare
or if there's free easy testing in the
community where you go to the grocery
store and you just test as a routine
matter or if they're included in a
surveillance population and that's one
area that i think we need to do better
in this country at least
is to actually do routine surveillance
to really understand what the level of
this silent spread is and the
persistence of virus over time
serology can be important to assess
immunity i think we'll see
an increase in serology for surveillance
and then um
i think
we'll see institutions
where
an outbreak would be costly we'll
continue to test
so you know i think that
what we're going to see is rapid tests
on site
with samples collected by trained
individuals i think that's the other
issue is that some individual people in
the public lay people don't really know
how to collect the sample and those of
us who've been
sampled by healthcare workers know how
uncomfortable it can be to get a really
good nasopharyngeal specimen
or maybe this high throughput testing on
site or in a reference lab as well
thank you dr engman our next question
what has been your biggest surprise with
diagnosing a symptomatic code in 19
patients
i think
one is the large number how large the
number of asymptomatic
individuals is
i was very surprised to over time to
know that it's larger and larger and
larger you know up now it could be 9 out
of 10 people without symptoms
the other issue is that asymptomatic
people are
possibly as likely to transmit virus as
symptomatic patients and we saw that
from that study from bahrain that i
mentioned a little bit ago
i'm not terribly surprised that
positivity
on the anagen test correlates with the
cycle threshold and molecular testing
that
makes sense that the molecular testing
is quite quantitative in terms of the
viral load
i am surprised that that rna can be
positive after intact virus has been
cleared and the evidence for that by the
way is that those samples are introduced
into tissue culture and
evidence of live virus can be seen in
those cultures and that they that you
can have samples that are rt
pcr-positive that do not contain active
virus
all right i think the finally i'm a
little surprised that serology
has not been implemented on a more
routine basis but i think that's coming
especially for healthcare workers where
you sort of want to know
your health care workforce how many
people have been infected
vaccinated monitoring vaccine efficacy
and antibody levels etc
and possibly we might even see some t
cell
assays developed that can
that might correlate better with
protection from future infection
dr eamon what lessons learned can we
leverage from kobit 19 to improve our
lab testing moving forward maybe for the
next pandemic
that's an excellent question i mean i
think
one of the things that we i think first
of all the testing
industry globally in academic labs and
in
corporations has been really amazing to
watch over the last several years it's
been outstanding
i think we could have done even better
if we'd established a set of
standardized control samples
that could be distributed to anyone who
wants to develop a test whether it's a
company or an academic lab for a
diagnostic test development
this way we're comparing apples to
apples and especially when people
publish those early studies about
sensitivity and specificity
they're they're using different sets of
samples
often they're from high tighter viruses
where it's very easy to detect a
positive
sample and get a sensitivity rate that's
much higher than you might get from an
asymptomatic or from somebody with
waning
viral load
and i think that there have been a lot
of work recently to establish in
proposals a pan-pathogen
metagenomic approach this is where you
basically can use rna sequencing to a
sample to characterize patient samples
without any knowledge of what the type
of pathogen could be viral bacterial
parasitic fungal
and also pan viral family pcrs to
investigate an outbreak for early
pathogen identification so
once you identify this then you can use
a specific pcr or antibody or antigen
test
and you don't even need to have isolated
organism all you need is the sequence
and you can produce all of those
reagents for diagnostic
purposes and surveillance
thank you our next question
the overall case fatality rate that you
mentioned does this include
vaccinated and unvaccinated
it does
uh
the the overall rate does but it's very
clear that deaths are much more likely
to occur in unvaccinated people
i haven't recently seen
the death broken out by vaccinated
versus unvaccinated but i'm pretty sure
those numbers are available
somewhere we'd have to look
now dr england
what kind of benefit do you see from
doing the sars
covi2 variant surveillance since omicron
is being the major variant with mild
symptoms out there now
i think
at the present time
it's
the the current
level of sequencing
that's happening globally and that gis
aid resource where people are submitting
sequences from all over the world has
been pretty remarkable
at tracking
uh
uh viral variant emergence and that will
continue unless people decide to drop
that which i think it's really premature
i mean i think
if you look at the omicron um
uh case fatality rate and the virulence
it's quite low and i think that's
especially as we move into our own
summer season here spring and summer
people are just not going to tolerate
some of the mitigation measures and i
think that if we drop our vigilance
on that global sequencing
and sampling effort
we might be caught in a bad place if the
new
variant does emerge
in the population there is already
i didn't point this out too much but in
that chart of the united states that ba2
variant is which is a subset of the
omicron is starting to
emerge and increase in frequency uh
compared to the previous
of the major omicron variant that
dominates at the present time so that
could then emerge but
it might be a non-omicron variant that
pops up later but nobody knows for sure
whether there even will be
another variant that emerges to dominate
the
global scene like omicron has and delta
before it
thank you dr engman now this question is
two parts first part do antibody levels
correlate with protection from covid19
and couldn't these levels simply be
measured and boosters given to people
whose antibodies fall below a certain
level
you know i think that when people first
developed
these serology tests that that was the
hope the hope is and actually
anyone here who works in a healthcare
organization that requires
titers for a variety of childhood
vaccinations be measured and boosters
given for measles or mumps rubella
whatever it may be
knows that they're basing that on the
result of a serology test
that's done as an adult well past that
vaccination time
i think the thought was that maybe the
same thing might be true
of sars kobe too that you could just
measure antibodies and once they fall to
a certain level
that then the person's not protected
anymore but the correlation between
antibody titers and
infectibility
is not straightforward and they're
people with
quite high tighter antibodies who get in
reinfected and sick
and people with low tighter antibodies
who as a population
do not get ill so that that's been a
little disappointing for people who
wanted an easy biomarker for
you know
protection from infection
uh there's been a lot of work on other
trying to identify other markers that
might be more useful that way and
there's some promising candidates but
nothing that
is emerging as the gold standard test to
see whether some
vaccinated or infected recovered person
is protected from reinfection
um and what was the second set part of
the question
or maybe i did
yes the second part was
um
sorry let me
pull back to the picture couldn't these
levels simply be measured and boosters
given to the people whose antibodies
fall below a certain level okay yeah i
incorporated that into my question that
it was the hope but i i think that that
is not turning out to be
as useful as people hoped
right
thank you for that
all right and next question and we have
so many questions coming in i do want to
remind our audience that any questions
that we are unable to answer today they
will be answered via email
at the email address you used for your
registration
okay
next question
now dr england there appears to be
little specific information regarding
the impact and the implications for the
transplant and oncology communicate the
communities with omicron's high level of
transmissibility
are these populations essentially
unvaccinated despite having had four
vaccinations
so
there was great concern and
justifiably so about
people who are immunocompromised for a
variety of reasons
transplant patients cancer patients etc
because of their potential increased
susceptibility to this infection
and
so there have been studies
well before we even started talking
about boosters
where some of those populations were
given
third doses fourth doses of vaccines and
those actually have been
reasonably successful at boosting
antibodies up to reasonable levels
whereas people after one dose or two
doses with who are transplant recipients
for example
made very little antibody and were
highly susceptible then to uh infection
presumably infection
susceptible
so
uh i wouldn't say that the
solution to protecting immunocompromised
patients is simply more and more
boosters
but it's made some
theoretical
head road into
solving that problem i think if i were
an immunocompromised person
i would be
vaccinated as many times as allowed and
practice social distancing and masking
and mitigation
measures
thank you dr ingman and we have time for
one final question
given how the lab workforce has been
impacted by covid do you see testing
changing to accommodate the staff
shortages
this great resignation as it's called
it's not clear that that's going to end
with a resolution of this pandemic if it
resolved i think a lot of people have
used these last few years to really look
at their own
personal lives their own financial
situations etc and making decisions
either to
change jobs to do something where they
can work from home which obviously isn't
viable for the laboratories
or
not re-enter the workforce so that's
that's one thing and i also think that
the impact on lab staffing depends on
the lab so
some labs have been able to manage these
surges in testing
by
shifting around personnel adding extra
shifts but others have either outsourced
or even closed temporarily because they
just couldn't handle those loads and i
foresee this variability in how
individual labs handle these surges
continuing but many labs have
implemented cross-training of people in
other parts of the laboratory to be able
to handle those increases
that might be
needed but temporary
and dr england i'm going to squeeze in
one final question here okay could you
just comment a little bit more on the
infectious profile based on the cycle
threshold view
uh yes i think that the um
there are a number of studies
that i pointed out this one from bahrain
that showed those 90 percent
uh
silent transmission
among 160
vac a 160 symptomatic and asymptomatic
index cases
what was found there though
is that the
there's no difference in the infectivity
rates of the index cases
depending on the high or low ct so
people who have
very high ct values low virus
are just as infective as people with low
although
if you look at the index cases
those who had symptoms
had much higher virus lower ct than
those without symptoms asymptomatic
people are likely to have high ct or low
virus so that was very interesting is
that um symptoms in the index cases
correlated with ct
but not in the
infectivity of the
cases
that arose from
contacts of those index cases so it's
very interesting
dr engman thank you so much for your
presentation and for your
insightful answers to all of our
questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
i think that first of all thank you
everybody for tuning in and for your
questions i've watched some of them
i just i shouldn't have i should have
been speaking but i come in and they're
very interesting they're many that we
were not able to answer
i think that we all should be
optimistic but also very vigilant as we
move through 2022.
this is not over now and it's there's no
guarantee it's going to
completely end here so i think all of us
need to work together and hopefully we
will emerge from this
better in our ability to diagnose and
manage
pandemics and smarter about how we
understand
viral pathobiology and immunity and
vaccination
thank you again dr ingman for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor diasporin for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
those for their interesting questions we
have quite a few questions we were
unable to answer due to time so those
questions
that we did not answer today and those
that are submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you for joining us and
have a great day
you